first of all congrats on the movie I
felt like I was having a heart attack
like halfway through it's very very
intense I'm gonna say that but so I'm
very curious the movie with the energy
of it it's I don't know how that could
be described or how is that described in
the script I'm curious if all four of
you could talk about reading the script
for the first time and what Josh and
Benny were trying how did that work for
you in terms of understanding the energy
well I think it's just like it's clearly
a movie made by New Yorkers because we
are just so desensitized like something
is always happening
we're always them overly stimulated so
like you know a New Yorker can keep up
with that you know whereas I think maybe
someone from like some more laid-back
lifestyle is like oh my god what was
that for me it just seems like a normal
day in the life you know sure
that's why years oh there's always
people who say yeah I can visit visit
New York but I want to live it yeah
exactly
but it didn't it read it didn't as
agonizingly phonetic I was that's I was
an odd like the tempo and what they
brought to it in their style and the
music and everything you could never
have imagined that from just yeah it was
a great script but you wouldn't imagine
stylistically what they ended up with
sure a lot of times I speak to actors
and they they say they can't watch
themselves on screen so I'm curious like
you premiere the movie last night here
at TIFF are you like immediately walking
out or do you want to experience it with
the you know with the whole energy of
that audience I feel like I needed a
moment after there's just uh
overwhelming a little bit the energy of
it it was just like things happening
very everywhere quickly trying to keep
up with and then BOOM so I had to find
myself at the end kind of like whoa I
was disoriented yeah yeah that's all I
was I need a drink Dena all day long was
was saying I can't wait to watch myself
tonight
and then I watched her watch it and she
kept nodding her head yes that's that's
the way you do it yeah I actually made
them let me screen it before visas I
would not want to see for the first time
in front of people so this way I saw it
I know what I look like I know the
things I'm not gonna like about myself
at any wise and then I could sit with
everyone and enjoy it actually notice
that Adam was even in the movie I am
curious what what is it like the the
Josh and Benny have been trying to get
this off the ground for a very long time
can you talk about that first meeting
with them and what made you feel safe in
their hands I just seen the other movies
that totally made me safe that how great
great everything they've done is and how
original and fresh and their
storytelling and just meeting them these
guys were so excited to make the movie
they were so passionate and
every-everything meant so much to him
that it was infectious and you wanted to
be on the team and we all joined in I
mean it was everything was as important
to us as it was to them by that by the
time I started shooting one of the
things that when you're working with two
directors I'm always curious are they
each one head of the of this like two
heads of the same snake or do you find
that one of them is more likely to give
you a note after a take and one is more
likely looking at cameras and lenses
benny Boone cos Ben's always on the boom
mic but there were times where he was
like whisper and little things and been
like oh yeah I don't know this time like
that lasts more let's do this like this
yeah yeah and look like so it's kind of
like it felt cool because it just felt
like we're all just a team and you know
kind of just we're all playing from all
angles and all had a role and it I don't
know it's weird as if it felt like we
were all kind of directors in a sense
which is how nice to me yeah right
anyone else know anything about Josue
Benny yeah I don't know what what do you
find that they were conflicted that they
go back and forth Benny would say no
it's fine we don't need another take and
Josh would say yes we do we do but in
the end they
always respected each other's opinion
and went with whatever the other thought
was the way to go they're definitely
brothers yeah they're yeah oh yeah they
they bicker for sure but you can tell
they're they really respect each other's
like talent you know I don't think one
thinks that they're better than the
other one doesn't handle that they're
both on top of everything yeah they both
ultimately make decisions together and
and like look he said it was cool but um
Josh would come in and talk to you on
occasion
literally right yeah you know he's a
foot away from me screams ever seen
damnit Benihana yeah that's on me yes
dude that was really funny as I wanted
my next question was so who ruined the
most takes and why for sure Julie no no
no no no there was no ruler so they I
don't think they look all cut in the
middle of anything they just if it's
something would happen at a out of a
mistake or or whatever whatever you want
to call it they definitely let it go and
find something out of it exactly there
was like magic and every take I think
you know there was something special
about each one um I I think Kevin
Garnett did a great job and um I'm just
curious what did you find that more
people wanted to visit you on this set
versus others because you have Kevin
Garnett it was it was like a big
visiting Center it wasn't a move visit
all my friends wanted to come your
friends employ yeah hilarious yeah we
were shooting a lot of hours and go late
and yes sure but you had a lot of
friends too
those are Fame paid people that taxi
Oh actually though can you share a
little bit about working with Kevin
because you're never really sure that he
has a really authentic energy on screen
can you talk a little bit about working
with him he's incredible
he just blew me away and I write
everything was great it was really good
at taking direction and he's very
focused and you can you can kind of say
like you like can you be more like that
or whatever and he would just get it
immediately on that the first he reacts
to everything yeah an actor as good as
any actor yeah he was in the moment he
was always there was it wasn't we will
we all got along so well we all got to
know each other quickly so there was it
was a very relaxed vibe when he was
there and his I remember any day being a
struggle was always kind of always fun
he respects the craft you know
oftentimes this can be something that
looks really easy and stuff and people
just like I [ __ ] I'll just come from
in it but uh he respected the craft and
he took his time and wants to learn and
then was always watching and looking and
listening and shows in his performance
because he's only every time I've seen
him play he's always so intense yeah I
love the way he looks at the opal yeah I
think I have to stop but I just really
want to say uh congratulations on the
movie and I'm happy that I don't feel
like the it's it captures that great
manic energy so well you know have a
fantastic day thank you good to see you